my joy
is far greater than my fatigue the pope
tweeted shortly after touching down in
rome
rather than sleeping on the flight home
he surprised reporters by speaking
candidly in support of gay priests
who am i to judge he said
he also said women should play a bigger
role in the church
journalists on board the aircraft burst
into a round of applause
the pope has received widespread praise
for his willingness to engage with
ordinary people that was particularly
clear during his trip to brazil
it's a trait few associated with his
predecessor
a beautiful welcome it was a fantastic
world youth day
pope francis offered us a fantastic and
moving vigil last night
an estimated three million people turned
out on sunday for the pope's last mass
in rio
he was received like a star and true
brazilian style of the crowd sang
and danced with fervor
the pope had a clear and simple message
for the faithful
the pope is counting on you
go and make disciples of all people amen
i mean pope francis has consistently
called on young catholics to shake up
the church
that message has now been heard by
millions
whether it's young people rocking at
mass surprise statements while on his
flight home
or spirited tweets one thing is clear
pope francis is more than comfortable
departing from convention
you